[Music]
maybe it's innate maybe society pushes
us to do it maybe it's a mix of both for
whatever reason it seems like we are
always in such a rush needing the next
thing wanting more and wanting it fast
we need to do things we need to get
places and once we get there we need to
want more what's next we ceaselessly ask
ourselves everything is always in
service for the next thing we exist in a
society that is almost entirely
preparatory for the future and perhaps
that is part of the problem that we are
told that what we are doing right now is
for what we will be doing next starting
as a young child kindergarten is for
elementary school elementary school is
for high school high school is for
college every step of the way we can't
wait until we get to be the bigger kid
in the next grade then if we choose to
attend we get to college and colleges
for our career then in our career each
level is for the next level we can't
wait until we work our way up and get
that big promotion or find the perfect
position we can't wait until we matter a
little bit more in a company or a little
bit more successful in our own and
suddenly someday many years down the
line our head bangs against the ceiling
we've made it as far as we could go
we're exhausted and we can't wait until
we can just put it all away and retire
not long after we might find ourselves
retired we might reflect back and wonder
to ourselves what was all that in all of
our desire for the next it seems like we
often neglect to ever stop and think
about what it's all for
what it's all going to wors hopefully we
will find some pride enjoyment and sense
of purpose in this moment of our
retirement induced reflection but if we
were not careful and we lived our life
as
one big sprint constantly unsatisfied
and chasing the next thing we might find
discomfort and regret in this moment a
profound realization that all of the
things we couldn't wait for all of the
things we were rushing to walls never
truly came in this moment we will be
looking back at our life with a small
slice of the pie left quickly turning
stale and we might wonder why we never
enjoyed the rest of it while it was
still fresh how did we miss it we might
wonder how did we wish it all away to
end up here to those who have most of
the pie still left it doesn't have to
come to this point in order to realize
this or to at least consider the idea
progression is great trying new things
evolving and working towards new goals
are all great but when it gets to the
point where it prevents us from ever
being able to appreciate that this
moment right now is also great perhaps
you've gone too far this moment is
meaningful it is a beautiful and
profound achievement in it of itself and
it is worth appreciating because you
don't get one big full pie at the end of
life you eat it all along the way
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder